oh boy am I gonna regret this video I've
been up since 5:00 in the morning I just
got back from London I'm [ __ ] tired
but I got a film of video today and I'm
had this video in the back of my mind
for a while so I thought hey let's let's
get it out there see what happens I'm
gonna talk about my favorite anime hey I
know what you're thinking oh oh I see
what he's doing it's gonna bring up
Naruto and bleach and he's gonna pretend
he doesn't know which one is which
oh that's some gold standard Beauty pie
comedy right there oh I get it
he's gonna bring up 90s American sitcoms
and call them animes that's that's a
good humor I bet next he's gonna say his
favorite animes friends now but for real
I used to watch a lot of anime I know
right
what a [ __ ] game I'm sorry calm down
I don't anymore I don't watch a lot
anymore there has been some good ones
recently like one punch man attack of
the Titan was alright alright maybe you
guys need to calm down a little bit it
wasn't that [ __ ] good [ __ ] tween
you think you know anime oh I'm gonna
tell you anime okay cuz I know I
remember the first any move I ever
watched because I remember I didn't
really use to get it I thought it was
like weird what is that weird Japanese
[ __ ] I don't get it isn't that just for
nerds then I realized how [ __ ] cool I
was
basically the first one I ever saw was
Ergo Proxy it was shown on Swedish
television and it was a sci-fi and I
never really got into sci-fi as well but
I thought this was the coolest thing
ever and I was so thrilled by the fact
that I was enjoying watching it it has
the best intro oh man it's so good
[ __ ] Smallville time
yeah I'm definitely regretting doing
this video already it also has the best
most fitting outro I have ever seen with
Radiohead paranoid android which fits so
good it was the same thing I thought the
same way about Radiohead and then I got
really into them and it became one of my
favorite bands so you can say this anime
introduced me to a whole new world which
I never thought I would like if I
remember correctly the story is about a
guy a mankind lives inside a bubble like
this giant has glass bubbles because we
polluted the earth original plot and
then he falls out of the bubble and then
he meets some new people but then he
realizes things about himself that he
didn't know before and there's like
these weird people around I really liked
it since this whole videos is
embarrassing already let's just get the
worst of the [ __ ] worst out of the
way
Ichigo 100% if that if that rings a bell
with you then we're on the same [ __ ]
level listen we'd be it we'd be we'd be
insta bros if you know it should go 100%
luckily I never met anyone else that had
actually seen this [ __ ] pathetic
piece of [ __ ] anime it's basically the
classic randomize guy for some reason
gets like three hot girls who's into him
which is like every guy's dream oh my
god oh yeah it's a little sexual Justin
Law it's very tastefully sexual okay
Sookie Oh Satsuki I remember it's all
coming back to me now Oh touhou ah no
spoilers but he picks the wrong girl and
oh no I'm glad we got that out of the
way cuz Jesus Christ that was pathetic
okay let's move on to something cooler
okay
berserk very famous anime very good it's
it's it's a bit old and you can tell on
the style and usually that turns me off
from watching older enemies because it
they just look they look like I don't
like that doesn't have a [ __ ] giant
eyes and bright colors I don't like that
but it's really good and I recommend it
it's a story about friendship and
rivalry it has the biggest plot twist or
maybe not plot twist I don't know how to
say without spoiling but basically it
starts off just completely normal
medieval [ __ ] you got horses you got
swords you got armor you got battles
everything is fine and you watch the
enemy up until a very end of episode 25
and you're like hey that's pretty good
this is pretty good that's pretty good
and then let's just say something
happens and if you're under 18 do not
read the manga because I read the manga
and I saw some things
[Music]
and the manga basically continues after
the the anime ends where this thing
happens where everything just [ __ ]
changes and my poor my poor teenage eyes
I saw some things I will never burn into
my retina no amount of bleach will able
will ever cure just don't read the manga
just don't I mean it do read the manga
it's [ __ ] great but just some parts
you might want to click through em I
mean skim through a little faster that's
all I'm saying there's the thing if you
if you read it you know exactly what I'm
[ __ ] talking about one thing about
that's really cool about the manga once
you get to a certain point is that you
can see the influences that it had on
the my favorite games which is Dark
Souls because here's the armor and you
can see the resemblance to Artorias as
well I think and our Toria is like the
ultimate badass guts is the ultimate
badass so it's really cool you guys
remember these the wheels from Dark
Souls Oh in the hunt the hunter's mark
hunter smart from blood-borne is
straight straight out from berserk and
oh my god here's the part I was talking
about jesus [ __ ] christ
yeah we're not we can't show that
there's no [ __ ] way the end the
trolls oh my god
it's just [ __ ] too much man I didn't
know he got the [ __ ]
but it's really good it's really it's
one of the best it's probably one of the
best another one that I really enjoyed
was and welcome to the nhk if I remember
it correctly
basically I I could relate so much to
this guy while I watched because he's a
total introvert completely lost on what
is doing in with his future he just
wants to be a shot in and escape from
the world I could relate to him so much
and I remember how it felt good in a way
to fully relate to what a character is
struggling with loneliness and oh my god
I didn't think this video could get more
pathetic but I I just did it another
favorite of mine is Mononoke shut the
[ __ ] up okay no I'm not talking about
Princess Mononoke every time all you're
talking about Princess Mononoke oh I
love Princess Mononoke
well well you [ __ ] fake-ass anime fan
you haven't heard a moaning okay is that
how you say okay Mononoke is a
collection of horror stories the art
style is absolutely amazing it's one of
the best I've ever seen it's just
incredible and like bright happy colors
mixed with her a really gruesome horror
story somehow it works really well it's
basically about a guy that's a medicine
man and he travels around and he
destroys his Mononoke which is like
demons or whatever to kill them he has
to find out what happened I loved
watching it and I really I really
recommend it just googling Mononoke and
you [ __ ] get all this [ __ ] this is
not the one this is the one I mean look
at the art styling so it's just so
pretty
another favorite of mine is gang could
so I don't know if that's how you say it
it's basically The Count of Monte Cristo
they go hard on the [ __ ] the art
style they have these patterns that was
made by some famous clothes designer why
do I care I do care that's why it's so
sad and it's got some really [ __ ]
cheesy intro oh oh
jean-jacques Bernal
[Music]
no no oh I just realized berserk has the
best [ __ ] intro by the way just like
these Japanese people who can't speak
English respect try to sing as I like
why did they talk like that
that's not blame that's not fair that's
how I should be fun
what I didn't know these were the lyrics
yeah it uh tell me why tell me why tell
me what you uh-huh
it's [ __ ] good it's so good look at
those muscles mane Oh number two on my
list Kaiba
not a lot of people know about this
anyway it's basically it's a sci-fi but
a love story but it's done in a kind of
Disney inspired style the artwork which
I love it's so pretty
it's hard to find pictures of this
[ __ ] anime as well because because of
this [ __ ] guy apparently his [ __ ]
name is Kaiba but here's how the art
side looks III [ __ ] love it it's so
pretty
very interesting sci-fi story where you
your body and memories can be
transferred to other people and the plot
twists got me that was very emotional at
the end I hated the intro
[Music]
they ain't intro [ __ ] sucks it's
really good it's right it's got a good
place in my heart this anime and you
don't have to judge me for it okay just
watch you yourself it's kind of hard to
watch it's kind of hard to get into so
if you're gonna watch this one you got
it you got to give it a little go okay
finally my favorite of everything oh boy
I posted about this before you might
know of blame but blame is the best
thing ever created
it's a cyberpunk cyberpunk it's a story
about a guy going through this endless
landscape is there's very little
dialogue you basically have to kind of
make up the story yourself or you kind
of have to interpret it your own way
which is my favorite way of storytelling
and I think that's why I like
blood-borne and Dark Souls so much
because throw the story in your face you
kind of have to just pay attention to
what's going on the way the scenery is
drawn in the manga is just absolutely
incredible the artist used to be an
architect and you can tell because it's
so well well drawn it has my favorite
style of a manga in in anything I've
ever read
it has one of the most interesting
stories I've ever read I love to just
come back and reread blame because every
time I read it it's a different
interpretation or you notice different
things and you discover new things and
it makes it fresh every time you go
through it and you can go through it in
a couple hours it's because there's so
little dialogue it's fairly short I have
some of my favorite characters I feel
really weird talking about this because
it feels so personal that's why I'm like
I don't
it's my baby one thing that's kind of
weird that I really like about blame is
because it has no nudity in it even
though it's a very adult like manga for
me that's very refreshing in a sense I
really shouldn't even matter but I to me
it feels like they risk they takes
itself more seriously in a way because
let's be honest Japanese people are
[ __ ] perverts I mean everyone is just
Japanese people are more honest about it
the fact that there's no weird sexual
undertone or stuff like that to distract
you from the story it is really nice
there's anything I would recommend from
this video check out blame if you want
to read something kind of like dark
undertone sci-fi stories I recommend it
I don't know why this this is just so
painfully awkward for me to talk about
because it really it really I think it
really will shine through in this video
how [ __ ] embarrassed I am right now
but anyway I hope you enjoyed this video
if it even makes the light of day I
don't know
but regardless maybe it was something
different I hope you enjoyed it let me
know if you have any recommendations
based on what I just talked about maybe
there's something I missed
and yeah let me know what you thought if
you checked out any of my suggestions
it's always cool to see if people enjoy
what you like and stuff like that I feel
like I should redo this video but I
don't think I I can bear I don't think I
can bear to do the go through this
painful experience again I hope you
listen thankful for you good it was for
me let me tell you okay that's it for
now stay awesome press
[Music]
you